keep turning up in the break that's a
very kind of your yeah so I am Dan web I
at down wrong at Twitter I also work on
the web team it to where and today I
wanted to talk to you about flight the
the title on the website is very brief
just because I was rushing to grab one
of the slots that was in the because I
can't think in the morning so had to be
in afternoon one so ya light wanted to
really kind of give an overview about
flight and what it is and why we created
it really so Oh a couple of months ago
maybe my colleague Angus who you
probably listen to any other room Iran
wrote this blog post introducing flight
we were really excited about this this
is actually code that runs all of
twitter com and most of tweetdeck at
this point and quite a few Twitter
properties so we've actually had this
thing running and been some battle
testing it for about a year or maybe
longer but at this point we're really
excited about bring it out and showing
the world we thought we anguished over
this blog post trying to make sure that
it sort of explained all the intent
behind flight and we put it out into the
world and then waited to see what the
world had to say about it and literally
this is no joke the first comment on
hacker news was this
so obviously the first thing we thought
is Oh for [ __ ] sake hacker news but
like in a in a in a sense it's a really
good question and I think like it does
bear elaborating on there are a ton of
client-side frameworks out now out there
now we couldn't possibly need one more
on the pile and we did think about this
and buy it you know we would seek to use
something if that was out there if
they're all possible and contribute it
wrote to it rather than creating a new
thing but you know we felt that what we
were trying to achieve was distinct
enough from these and I want to explain
a bit about that so to set the scene
when i joined the web team it was not
long after new twitter was was out there
new twitter at its time was quite ahead
of its game it was a fully client-side
MVC application at the time when some i
don't even know when we're the backbone
was out at this point or any of the
other frameworks so it was built on a
sort of homegrown MVC framework because
there wasn't anything sort of big at the
time and you know doing a lot of really
interesting stuff and like a lot of MVC
frameworks it had the structure that
you'd expect so this isn't real code
I've what I've done with these code
examples is more tried to kind of
generically illustrate the kind of
conventions that you see in MVC
frameworks rather than writing code for
a particular one because I'm not
pointing at faults in a particular
framework just trying to illustrate the
kind of thing that we have so obviously
we had we had models models you can you
can request an object which is a model
you can call functions to mutate those
objects and do actions like following in
our case and in a lot of cases the these
things were asynchronous so you had a
callback to do something with that
result as well as just calling methods
directly and you can actually add event
listeners so other objects can listen to
follows that happen in
application generically we had
controllers controllers will typically
look a bit like this you have some kind
of URL Rooter that points to a
particular controller in action and
inside that we we're finding some tweets
by actually require calling them the
home timeline method on the user model
and then with those tweets we create
some views and then we stuff those into
the Dom somewhere views looks a little
bit like this we we still use mustache
and similar to how we used this backward
on Newt we're typically they render
things but they can also render sub
views as well so in this case we're
getting all of our tweets and then we're
creating a new tweet view out of those
and then rendering those and put and
putting those into the Dom so we end up
having this structure where controllers
would typically talk talk to the route
or would talk to the controller and the
controller with talk two views and
models beautiful models I think Jeremy
oshkosh is trying to interrupt the time
so these are you talk to models and
other views so there's a lot of
relationships and this is actually a
real slide that we had that we tried to
document all of the relationships in in
in Newt where's you I at the time and as
you can see it's complicated it's
whether there are a lot of relationships
and hierarchical relationships and event
relationships between all kinds of
different pieces and the thing is is I
think you know doesn't necessarily look
it but twitter com is quite a
complicated you I so this complexity was
necessary there is a ton of stuff going
on there and a ton of code needed to run
all of that stuff so that's fine that we
need this stuff to be complicated but
what the situation we had is that when
we added features what we were doing
with is adding more boxes and lines to
that diagram and increasing the amount
that
one engineer would need to understand
they need to really understand most of
them all those boxes and arrows in order
to effectively do some work because they
can't just like look at one bit of the
code and change it without knowing all
of the things that refer to it and
knowing whether than there would be
knock-on effects so how do we have a
complex application with lots of sort of
interdependencies and how do we make it
like easy for engineers to think about
so no matter how many features you add
you still it's still just as easy to
think about as when you had you know one
control on the page and the answer
really that we went for is we we were
all about decoupling we wanted every
single thing to every single sort of
representation in the UI to be
completely decoupled and not know
anything about any of the other parts of
the UI all and there are lots of
different ways I mean in a sense MVC
kind of at least sort of titans these
these couplings so it and it gives the
structure to the couplings but we wanted
to go further than that we wanted to
make sure that one UI element does not
know where its data comes from it does
not know or even care if any of the
particular components are on the screen
everything is just completely
independent and this is sort of I think
where we've gone a step further than the
most other frameworks in this respect
the way they're kind of pretentious
stupid way of looking at it is it sells
really we want each cell in a body which
is the extremely complex thing isn't
aware of what's outside it it just
listens for changes in chemicals around
it and and does its own thing but in
aggregate these cells that don't know or
care about the cells next to them create
something really complicated and the way
to get to that is the same way that
sells get to that the components need to
have this very very simple contract with
the outside world and rather than know
they've got a hold on to a view object
in the view of views have a render
method and they also have a reference to
some other object and they have to know
about the the API to that particular
object we want just this really simple
thing in the same way that sells listen
to changes in chemicals around them so
we yep we're heading for entirely
self-contained components my
non-pretentious way of looking at this
is is if the poo is trapped in the box
then it only smells when you open it
well well it's trying to explain here is
that if everything is completely
self-contained we we don't care what's
written in any one component we can
refactor the whole thing as long as it
continues to do its job we can put any
old crappy old code in there and we'll
because we can refactor that when we've
got time we don't have to worry about
some crappy design decisions in one part
of the application having like a an
effect on on that the application as a
whole and not being able to refactor
that so how did we achieve that with
flight well we already I'm always been a
great advocate of making use of what we
have and going with the flow of the
platform and in this case the browser
rather than trying to create paradigms
that sort of live alongside it so what
do we have in the in the browser well we
have we have the DOM and how can we make
use of the Dom rather than kind of bash
it into shape well the one nice thing I
think the one elegant piece the facility
that the Dom provides is actually event
an event bubbling and and the way that
events can be triggered at certain
points in a document structure and
because hopefully your document secure
in your markup is actually give some
structure to the application that the
way that events bubble up through that
structure is
a really useful way to carry messages
around the application it's got this
inherent hierarchy so the some the
tweets the markup for the tweets is
inside some markup that represents a
timeline and that markup is inside the
body of the page and so on this is this
is all structure that actually maps to
the way this application works and we
can make use of that we have a vent
bubbling so we take advantage of all of
this and an essentially a flight
component in the simple words as
possible is an object that has a
reference to a dom node so it's a simple
JavaScript object it has a property
called node at that point to a single
Dom node and it and there are three
things that it can do it can manipulate
that node so it can change classes on it
can put new markup into it can do me and
change styles on it if if you really
need to it can trigger event on that Dom
node so if it wants to alert the outside
world to something that's happened
within it then it can fire an event and
say okay someone clicked me and I think
this is and they mean that they want to
retweet tweet ID 55 for instance and
they can also listen for events they can
anything that they might care about that
happens in the outside world like some
new data coming in or a user clicking on
that node or some sub part of that node
they can listen to that event and then
in and respond so to get sort of right
to the meat of it I'm not sure how many
people have seen flight ok I will do
this in a medium pace there so this is a
flat component the it's essentially
quite simple the where you start when
you're reading a flight component is
down here initialize now what initialize
we'll run that when the time the a an
instance of this component because you
can see this like a class you make many
instances of one component and
each Dom node gets its own incidence of
this component so when that attached
happens when a new instance of the
component is made and attached to a Dom
element then initialize is called and
this is where you just normally set up
event handlers so in this case this is
sort of like a generic toggler thing it
listens to a click on the node and and
just kind of flicks flicks a class so
you'll see we set we set up the event
handler and then that's the event
handler really simple and then you can
put other bits of state in there and
other methods and and basically this is
your little bit of code that puppy
puppets a Dom element and that's that's
all there is to flight really this is
this is what you get but it enables us
to kind of take advantage of this this
decoupling your app basically becomes a
collection of these components all all
not knowing about each other just all
kind of doing their own thing in
complete isolation and the way that you
actually sort of structure your app and
composer is is basically just by taking
a collection of these components and
attaching them to pieces of the Dom so
you can say why my navigation component
can attach to the top nav and I'll
attach this toggler to some selector
passing some options to for what the
toggle clasp is called and this is
basically how how the whole thing works
so the idea is is instead of
understanding the the diagram before and
all of these relationships that all
point all the all different other parts
of the application when you're actually
writing or adding functionality or
changing functionality all you're doing
is considering one single component at a
time you don't have to understand how
the whole thing works you just have to
look at the component you need to change
or the component you need to add
understand how that works and then make
your changes so instead of that giant
diagram you only really need to
understand something like this my tub
this is a toggle component it you if I
is enable and disable events to the
outside world and it listens for clicks
and that's literally all you need to
understand so with that you your your
poo is trapped in its box whatever
happens inside that toggle is very
localized to that particular component
the nice thing about this and sort of a
lot of this relates to the previous talk
on iop is that we don't have to resort
to marks for tests we because everything
is so atomic and and one component
doesn't even care that there might be
other components on the page you have
this great environment for tests you
take a single component one at a time
you fire events on it and check that it
does what you want it to do and and then
you check that it finds the events that
you expect it to have and just you're
simply testing this this contract which
is a relatively easy to understand we
have a tool for that called flight
jasmine it's basically sort of a set of
jasmine helpers that allows us to test
these contracts a small example of that
is if we wanted to write sir shins about
this we just be able to say okay
describe this component called toggle it
would set up this component essentially
what it would do is gives you a fresh
piece of markup for every for every
single test it attaches a fresh instance
of that node to it and then it runs a
single test so there's no test pollution
you're just testing this one thing at a
time you get a fresh incidents every
single time and you do a new basically
doing stuff like this so you can you can
spy on event so you this this test is
just if you click it does it fire the
enabled event and then you as you can
imagine you just kind of write a test
for each one of those things that we
have in our contract here and and you
don't you have pretty nice test coverage
so how do we apply this to twitter com
and something that you know
is non-trivial well essentially what
what we've done on top of this is it
sort of have this reasonably hard
separation between UI components and
data component so what we wanted to do
is have UI components whose only job is
to is manipulate the UI and typically
they take a browser event like a click
or a key press and then they they do a
little bit of logic to work to turn it
into a higher level an application event
so for instance you might have a follow
button and a follow button UI component
that will sit on top of it it will
listen for clicks and then fire an event
called follow or you I follow in using
our naming conventions and the user ID
would be done wrong for instance what
what then happens is we have data
components which are which are just
normal components just like the one you
saw but their only job is to talk to the
server or whatever other wherever else
you tore your data so they normally sit
on the document because there because in
the example of follow we we want to
listen to follow events wherever they
come from they can come from anywhere in
the UI so we listened to the whole
document listening for those follow
events to come up and they're making the
requests when the request comes back
they they fire another vent a broadcast
an event that says the follow of user
dan wrong was successful or arid and so
on and then the UI components can can
listen to the successor error and
actually should reflect that in the UI
and this is essentially how pretty much
everything works in twitter com the nice
thing is is that say if you click the
follow button you also wanted to update
your following count on the page then
the the you just basically link that to
the result event so you add a new
component which is the follower count
component for instance and you you just
listen for the yes the follow was
successful and increment the count but
the other stuff that you'd previously
written you don't care about that that
could be taken away it could not be
there at all and everything could still
work
no code no code is required to be
changed in the existing stuff you're
simply adding extra behavior arm I mean
what we tend to do is further to that is
though we implement a logger this way
previously we would have calls to our
logger code inside all of our models and
stuff so if we wanted to log when a
follow happened on the UI we would
actually like have a method call that
said log this thing happen but now we a
logger is a component that just watches
over the application and and just
listens for things that it cares about
and logs them it's completely separate
to all of our application logic and it
literally just sort of sits here and
listens for events just like anything
else and sends them to the server and so
to scale like I mean it I suppose it
looks something like this more
components more events being fired but
the point is you don't need to
understand this it's irrelevant the
overview all you need to understand is
under standard want is one component at
a time so the more we add and the more
complexity we add we don't actually add
to the mental overhead of being able to
work on this system but that is just our
architecture that isn't the flight way
of doing things we only we only
prescribe the component architecture and
the event mechanism we don't care what
templating you use we don't care whether
you do that templating on the client or
the server we don't make any assumptions
based on that at all we don't care where
you keep the state whether it's in sort
of model like objects or whether you
defer all that to the server it's all up
to you we just give you this way of
enforcing this coupling and so I suppose
the answer to the original question why
not just use angular well it's it's not
equivalent to angular I think in in many
ways I'd call it a it's a framework for
making frameworks you it's a way of
handling communication and decoupling
and you add your own architecture on top
an example of that is this thing that's
popped up just recently Icarus actually
sort of adds a model layer by by adding
some code to components so instead of
the data components that we have which
are quite raw they the data components
represent models and they have change
events that you can about you can bind
to and so on so and I'd love to see you
no more of this kind of thing that let's
lay a different UI paradigms on top and
you know make more assumptions about
different ways of doing things so it's
kind of a to bring your own architecture
really so what's next well we've got
that we've got a lot going on at the
moment we we just got a new logo to this
F thing Danny yes sir there's some
t-shirts coming probably stickers hadn't
thought much past that but yeah I think
it would be great to actually because we
have this sort of really reusable really
decoupled thing and there's been quite a
few components that sort of do more
general things that could be used in
lots of different apps coming coming out
there's there's a component the does
local storage and yeah a few other ones
that are popping up I'd love to see more
than that more of that and maybe we we
create a central repo for those another
thing that I'm really excited about but
we've only sort of thought through a
little bit is we think that this
architecture could map to web components
in a really really elegant way and
polymers just came out which I I love
the idea of it's obviously very new and
want to keep an eye on that for a while
but I could imagine web components and
flight becoming quite an interesting
thing so if you want to check it out
it's github com / twitter / flight we
have a Twitter account predictably which
is at flight yell be around if anyone's
interested in chatting about flight we
have we thought as everyone's going
downtown tomorrow that we pick a
drinking establishment and sort of post
up there so if anyone wants to come and
ask questions or chat about flight love
to hear are people using it and whether
you hate it or not love to have a
drunken argument about JavaScript me to
anyone into that yeah we'll be at eight
there are eight and Palace Saloon right
in downtown thinking tomorrow night and
come and chat to me we if you want to
come and work with flight at Twitter
come and chat to me because we have lots
of interesting web rolls coming up so
cool thank you very much